[Music]
the parents of a british teenager killed
in a collision with an american
diplomat's wife are in the u.s to give
evidence in a lawsuit against her
we're going to talk to them in just a
moment but we want to remind you about
harry dunn
his case has been in limbo since ann
sekulas returned to the u.s
she could face more than a dozen years
in prison but last year
the state department refused to return
her to britain to face trial
the family wants the new administration
to reverse that ruling
as mts taeyab reports harry dunn's
parents quest for justice has been taken
up by some of the world's most powerful
leaders
at the g7 summit last month uk prime
minister boris johnson said he was
working on it with president joe biden
he is actively engaged in the in the
case as
as you know he has uh his own personal
reasons for feeling very deeply about
the issue
and uh he was extremely sympathetic but
this is not something that either
government can uh can control very
easily
on thursday the 19 year old's parents
tim dunn and charlotte charles
gave in-person depositions out of
virginia court as part of the civil case
they brought against
and seculas for damages the american
mother of three admits to driving on the
wrong side of the road before the
collision which killed harry outside a
british military base
in august of 2019. sakulas fled the uk
after the crash claiming diplomatic
immunity as the wife of a u.s
intelligence official
triggering the dunn family's
extraordinary legal battle
that has already taken them to the white
house president donald trump invited
them for a meeting there in late 2019
where
unbeknownst to them ann seculas was
waiting in an adjoining room
they declined mr trump's offer to meet
with sakula saying they weren't
emotionally ready
and later described the experience at
the white house as traumatic
now a new president occupies the oval
office
one with a similar history of loss and
one who they hope will help them get the
justice
they so badly want for cbs this morning
fiesta
london now a representative for ann
sakulas told cbs news they have no
update for us at this time